[Music]
Luke settle this satellite that
ridiculous song rain on your wedding day
it's ironic because they chose that day
to get married
what kind of fairytale world is Alanis
Morrissette live in Canada right um I
might as well start with something we
actually know right that's a neat Club I
bet once they see one of our movies
ladies will come flocking I promise you
there isn't a single female behind those
doors you had a focus I know I'm trying
to fix that
easy there Romeo its mr. messengers
daughters the principal ever brain rest
your day go see with caution
at this age it's like we speak different
languages to bomb all that and a bag of
chips oh snap
he's going to ask out key I mean
actually have a chance with this girl
are you gonna do it
[Applause]
km/s huh will you go out with me
I'm raising lived on my own I didn't
realize her a single mother single
father
[Music]
Wow stop staring at all Sarla
I bet you've never got in trouble when
you were a kid anything you wish you did
[Music]
Kent I can see your car we went out a
few times I can hear the average high
school relationship last for 26 days
like you like the idea of me it's over
that's it
[Music]
for the first time in 10 years I feel
happy and I'm ready to fight for my
happiness you're perfect
[Music]
[Applause]
when it now takes a second wait for it
wait for it wait for it wait for it oh
and there god I love the net
[Music]